We're going to put everything, but
the data into the weather app's shell.
The HTML contains a header,
an empty forecast card,
a dialogue for adding new cities,
and the loading indicator.
Notice that the forecast card and
the dialogue
are hidden by default and
the loading indicator is visible.
We also need to include the styles and
any images our app needs to run.
When designing a more complex app,
content that isn't needed for
the initial load can be requested
later and inCached for future use.
For example, we could defer
the loading of the new city dialogue
until after the first run experienced
and we have some idle cycles available.